this operation warp speed update today
we continue to have good news to report
as of today shipments of vaccine
will have been delivered to every
delivery site identified by public
health jurisdictions for our first wave
of shipments
i hope that every american has been as
heartened as so many of us at hhs and
dod
have been to see heroic healthcare
workers and
vulnerable americans getting vaccinated
this week
i had the chance to see this work
firsthand myself at two sites
at george washington university hospital
and this morning at medstar
georgetown university hospital what i
took away from those visits
is this while operation warp speeds
delivery of vaccines on this time frame
is extraordinary
administering these vaccines can feel
quite ordinary
at gw they were administering vaccines
just like they do
any other vaccines but with all the
appropriate social distancing
precautions
at georgetown this morning the director
of pharmacy jeff cox
showed me the pfizer packaging that he
had received
showed me the gps tracking and the cold
chain storage tracking devices that
connect directly
in to general purna's command center
where every single pfizer box is
tracked and monitored on temperature
control for excursions
and he showed me their cold storage
facilities
show and he walked me through this very
simple
thawing mixing and extraction process
and he said other than that this is
covered
this is pretty standard this is what we
do
and that's been the message from very
virtually every partner
that we are working with in this
endeavor every hospital
fedex ups mckesson cvs walgreens
this is what we do we have a great deal
of work in the coming months to get a
vaccine to every american who wants one
but we are confident in our approach to
using
the health care providers and
institutions like hospitals and
pharmacies
that do such a good job of providing
tens of millions of vaccines to
americans every year
for next week we have allocated another
approximately 2 million doses of
pfizer's vaccine
for jurisdictions to use and if
modernist vaccine is authorized by the
fda
in the coming days we have allocated
nearly 5.9 million doses of that product
as many of you know on tuesday the fda
released the analysis that it will use
to brief its independent advisory
committee meeting tomorrow
the agency concluded that the vaccine is
94.5 percent
effective in reducing the incidence of
covid19 among the treated group
which far exceeds the standard fda has
set forth for an emergency use
authorization and they concluded that
the vaccine
is safe if and when the modern vaccine
is authorized it will have gone through
the same rigorous procedures that
the pfizer vaccine did and that every
ows
vaccine receiving emergency
authorization will go through
that includes clinical trials much
larger than many trials many vaccine
trials
an independent data safety and
monitoring board that oversees those
trials the drug companies
own ethical standards and checks and
balances
the fda's independent transparent
advisory committee meeting
the fda's transparent guidance standards
for emergency use authorizations for
coveted vaccines
and finally the fda's career scientific
experts applying
the standards that they have publicly
shared
we've been heartened to see that
americans vaccine confidence is rising
substantially according to an abc
poll this week more than 8 in 10
americans say they plan to take the
vaccine
and kaiser today announced 70 percent so
just vaccine confidence
is surging we still have much work to do
to ensure that all americans understand
the value of these safe and effective
vaccines but it's clear that many
americans are learning that these
vaccines are safe
and extraordinarily effective and as we
get more and more healthcare workers or
vulnerable seniors
vaccinated and they go through the
experience as i was able to see with
healthcare workers this morning doctors
and nurses from the er
from labor and delivery from icus at
medstar georgetown university hospital i
asked each one of them getting
vaccinated how it felt
getting the vaccine every single one of
them said
i didn't feel it as much as i feel the
flu vaccine shot
and had good experiences and as the word
gets out as they talk to their friends
their colleagues
their neighbors vaccine confidence in
the united states
will just increase by word of mouth
by trusted sources every single day
finally i want to remind americans that
there are two authorized antibody
treatments that
operation warp speed has supported that
can actually help prevent
hospitalizations in those patients
with the highest risk for severe disease
those are individuals 65 and above
and individuals who have comorbid
conditions that put them
at risk of hospitalization from covid
if you test positive and you fit in
those categories
please speak to your health care
provider immediately
because the best time to get those
antibodies is not when you show up in
the emergency room
but soon after being diagnosed with
covet
we've allocated over 330 000 doses of
these treatments
to all states and territories and many
states do have
product available even as we have people
entering into the hospital
with covid so again if you've tested
positive for covin 19 and at risk for
severe disease based on age
weight or underlying health conditions
or or if you've got a loved one who
may fall into that category there may be
a therapeutic option that could help
keep you out of the hospital
please talk to your health care provider
i also want to note another success that
we announced yesterday that's fruits of
the public-private partnerships that we
built
to expand testing yesterday the fda
issued an emergency use authorization
for the first
fully at-home diagnostic test for
covet-19
that does not require a prescription
this product was developed by illume
with the 30 million dollars in support
from the nih
rad x program which is the diagnostics
arm of operation warp speed
radix has invested nearly half a billion
dollars in not only development of
breakthrough testing options
but also expanding the production of
these options
the loom's test will cost about thirty
dollars and the company expects to be
able to make
millions per month in the coming year
even with the emergence of these new
tools we are not
at the finish line yet especially as we
approach the holidays
and in the coming months we've all got
to continue taking steps to keep
ourselves our loved ones and our
communities safe
it's the three w's wash your hands watch
your distance
wear your face coverings when you can't
watch your distance and avoid settings
where you're going to let your guard
down and not do those things like
overcrowded indoor restaurants or bars
and especially those household
gatherings they get multiple households
together friends and neighbors
you eat you drink you let your guard
down then
you think that because you know people
they can't be infected you can't infect
them
you're not symptomatic you're not going
to infect them this is how the disease
is spreading right now
and this is what's leading to cases
which will lead to hospitalizations and
tragically
leading to fatalities so we have we have
the tools in our hands right now
to bridge to the days that are upon us
we used to say to bridge to the
weeks and months ahead it's bridging to
the days that are right
upon us now but we all have to act
responsibly
and we'll get there because as we as we
look to
next week and the ongoing holiday season
my goal is for everybody that's here now
to be here next year for the holiday
season thanks to the vaccines and
therapeutics that the heroes of
operation warp speed in america's
biopharmaceutical industry are bringing
to you
but you got to make it to that point
through responsible behaviors
to get to the moment when you can get
vaccinated so with that said let me turn
things over to dr slowly
for a scientific and development update
thank you mr secretary
hello everybody just uh briefly i hope
you had a chance to look into the
moderna
submission for verpack and the fda
comments
i think they underline and demonstrate
again how
effective these messenger rna vaccines
are
and uh also describe very clearly their
very good
safety profile just want to highlight
two things
uh look at the kaplan-meier curves and
look at
efficacy after the first dose 10 to 14
days after the first dose
maximum efficacy is already achieved of
course it doesn't mean this is a one
dose vaccine because
people need got their second dose
two weeks later but it just means that
onset of efficacy is very fast
after immunization and we should start
to see
an impact in the very high risk
populations that are being
immunized as we speak the second thing
that's really interesting is the
apparent
protection against infection as detected
by pcr detection of virus
on day 28 in the study population that
has shown
anywhere between 60-65 protection which
i think is very exciting after one dose
again we'll see that data coming up
after second dose in the next few weeks
uh based more on the serological
endpoint than a virological endpoint
and i think that would be very important
from a public health perspective
at least in the short term i expect that
protection to be quite significant maybe
its duration
against infection may not be as
long-lasting as the protection against
disease
uh would be finally on moderna
uh as you have shown in in a scene sorry
in their announcement
uh 20 million doses will be delivered
by the end of the month and and i think
that's really
uh excellent uh pfizer just to remind
you that we are working very closely
with the company
to ensure that we can uh support and
help them
uh address all the challenges in
continuing to increase their capacity
and output
and also at the same time discussing how
we may
come to an agreement on the first option
for an additional 100 million
of doses next in the portfolio is the
johnson and johnson janssen's vaccine
tomorrow we will close recruitment in
the phase 3 trial with about
43 to 44 000 subjects
recruited really an outstanding
performance in terms of
the volunteers which we really warmly
thank
uh for their generous participation into
the trial
the trial is accruing cases
uh very quickly we hope that
we may be able to assess efficacy
first time early in january and maybe a
final time
late in january we just had this morning
yet another meeting to discuss
the supply chain and how we can optimize
uh availability of vaccine doses even
faster than we were thinking
uh early on uh given the speed of the
clinical trial development
and have vaccine doses in february and
march
already impacting the us population so
we're very hopeful there
on astrazeneca we are about 23 000
subjects
recruited in the phase 3 trial we expect
that trial to come to
mostly its completion in terms of
recruitment by the end of this year
or very early in january and case to
accrue
again during the month of january with a
readout probably in
february we're also continuing to
progress on the supply chain
with with the accumulation already
stockpiling of vaccine doses the two
protein vaccines
also continue to progress you have
signed the announcement you have seen
the announcement by
uh sanofi gsk uh with some delay
vis-a-vis phase three trial plans
uh and the novovax vaccine is is is
really on the starting blocks
towards phase three trials finally i'd
like to just close on the therapeutics
we are supporting four programs as
priority programs
the illi monotherapy monoclonal antibody
as well as
the cocktail program
we've ensured access to 950 000 doses
of the monotherapy monoclonal it's being
shipped very significantly
mr secretary just shared with you the
numbers there
uh likewise with regeneron we have
an agreement and secured access to 300
000 doses of the cocktail mix of
monoclonal antibody from regeneron and
we were discussing
additional access to additional doses
likewise
with eli lilly astrazeneca we have an
agreement
where they're testing their very long
half-life monoclonal antibodies
as prophylactic
therapeutic prophylactic medicines let's
call them
either in subjects at very high risk of
acquiring the infection
and the phase 3 trial has started
already recruited 300 subjects and is
currently in the pose
for the as planned uh review of safety
by the data safety monitoring board
before
further recruitment in the trial goes on
and also
in a a post-exposure prophylaxis trial
where people
that have been in contact with people
who are infected and
are suspected to potentially be
incubating the virus
are treated with the monoclonal to
prevent
their progression into into infection
and disease
and then the fourth program is the
oncoimmune
merck partnership now program very
important to treat patients in more
advanced stages of disease with very
significant impact
in in the interim analysis of their face
free trial on
mortality outcome exciting frankly
progress there
but on the other hand as expressed uh by
myself
and mr secretary yesterday you know
disappointing
level of usage of the monoclonal
therapies
in the hospital setting well for
patients that are infected but not
hospitalized
we really hope to see a much much higher
level
of usage of of the doses that are
delivered
to the uh healthcare facilities where
our surveys for now they're not yet
fully complete but
you know they show anywhere between five
percent and 20 which for uh
hospital preventing and therefore
life-saving
uh intervention uh in in this setting
really is
is not acceptable so we we look forward
to that
improving on that i will stop and pass
on to my co-leader
general perna thank you and mr secretary
thank you as always
so a very exciting week uh albeit only
the third day
work day of the week uh just really a
lot of good things
occurring as we execute the initial
shipments
that went out i would tell the team or
tell everybody listening that we've been
able to watch the whole process from
beginning to end
partnered with pfizer we had senior
leaders
collaborating with their senior leaders
literally on the floor
as we were as they were packing and
getting ready to distribute boxes this
weekend
to actual loading of the trucks right
really just an excellent collaboration
uh between odf bias ows excuse me and
pfizer
very impressed with the teamwork there
but then we extended it
right uh through uh security of the
shipments
with the u.s marshals and their ability
to track the coordination of handoffs
down to fedex ups and then down to the
final administration sites
where we dropped off the vaccine where
the cdc
had people throughout the country to
observe the receipt of the product
really to just get lessons learned and
learn how it's being received
the comfort of people receiving it how
they unload the box
how they go ahead review instructions
and initiate
execution of administration we've been
seeing it all over the news
people getting doses of vaccine really a
remarkable
end-to-end uh effort now
easily easily uh said very difficult to
do
uh and i'm grateful for everybody that's
been a part of that because
as we get going we want to learn lessons
rapidly improve
everything we're doing so that we can
expand
distribution every day every week
every month to the american people in
that light
as we talked about earlier this week we
are and the secretary just highlighted
we are on track with all the deliveries
that we said we were doing
uh the volume was a 145
on monday 425 yesterday
and 66 today right so that was our get
out of the gate get going really see
ourselves learn a lot
now tomorrow we're going to be at 886
deliveries right we're going to 886
additional locations in the united
states
so it is about a steady drumbeat cadence
of delivery of vaccine out to the
american people
secretary alluded to it but let me i
want to highlight
two uh points uh or one point with two
examples
uh so we can see everything
uh from manufacturing through
distribution
down to administration sites in
when it comes to what's happening with
the vaccine
two points i want to highlight we had
two
trays of pfizer vaccine that arrived in
california
in two separate places and as we were
tracking the temperature
we noted that the temperature actually
got colder than minus 80.
went to -92 we locked
those trays down pfizer uh
and ows working with fedex and ups
they never left the truck right and we
returned them immediately back to pfizer
uh and we
sent immediate shipments to replace
those two trays
we're working with the fda now cdc fda
and pfizer
to determine if that anomaly is safe or
not
but we were taking no chances and we
could see that
the second example all the way on the
other side of the country in alabama
two trays were received at one location
same anomaly
right it went to 92 minus 92.
again we were able to stop and
quarantine
the vaccine get a replacement shipment
immediately to alabama
and now we're just working through the
forensics to determine
uh if the vaccine is still good
etc etc learning but the key is we could
see herself and we were able to take
action i applaud
right uh pfizer really remarkable effort
uh fedex and ups and the participation
of that
so those are types of the lessons we're
we're working our way through
as the secretary talked about last night
we
allocated up to 2 million doses of
vaccine for pfizer
out to the jurisdictions they're working
through
you know their planning and where they
want that vaccine to go
and those deliveries will start in our
cadence
again on monday tuesday wednesday for
deliveries
right it's a constant flow of vaccine
always
expanding the distribution network in
every
state that we're really going for
we are continuing our efforts as we
talked about on monday
with the long-term health care
facilities right i would tell you uh
ohio and connecticut are all set
underneath the cdc federal program
to begin long-term health care
facilities on friday and saturday as we
said
this week really a great effort to start
our scale
up we know that florida and west
virginia
are also have started long-term health
care facilities
utilizing emts and or another contractor
as the state's decided that the point
being
is we're already doing long-term health
care facilities
and come monday we will be
at over 1100 uh different locations
starting long-term long-term health care
facilities
and that will rapidly expand thousands a
day
into our process over seventy thousand
facilities
uh that we've coordinated with uh and
that we're working
the plan for distribution cvs and
walgreens are leading this
effort uh in collaboration with the cdc
so we are
really aggressively working uh on the
offense
uh to take care of these great uh these
great americans
in these facilities so really i'm very
very excited about where we're going
with that and
we'll continue to report on that
accordingly um
as we uh talked briefly about uh what
what is next
right so i just talked about some
tactical execution
of the delivery but we're already
expanding our thoughts to
vaccine dosages is becoming more and
more available
as as we're more confident with the
manufacturing
and distribution and so what do we want
to be able to enable
next uh so uh the cdc and 19
pharmacy chains right are collaborating
i received a very extensive briefing on
saturday i have participated
in uh the call with the 19 pharmacies
and the cdc and they've established
and are working through the final
details to enable
governor plans about
allowing access to all these facilities
throughout
our country so in simple terms
when as soon as we can turn the key on
on this and we're looking sometime about
mid-january
as doses really become available but
won't be locked to one date it'll be
driven by states decisions
and vaccine availability what we see
is an expansion of capacity
for administration of vaccines up to
about 37
000 brick and mortar uh facilities right
this is really just a powerful
collaboration
with the pharmacies and the cdc
but most importantly enabling the
governor's
uh plans to expand uh vaccination
throughout their states
uh as we transition to other um
uh really critical groups so really
excited about that
and we'll keep you updated as we go
forward on that
um the last thing i would tell you um
and it's not lost on you if you've heard
me talk before
um this this is the beginning right it
was a great start
but every day we have to hold ourselves
accountable to very high standards
we have to continue to learn and we have
to
just get better every day because at the
end of the day
it is about safe and effective vaccines
and therapeutics for the american people
i would leave you with this it's a whole
of america
approach uh and it's being illuminated
uh through the state's plannings
and execution as you saw really want to
give them
kudos for the elaborate work and
execution
accordingly i will again re-emphasize
as the secretary mentioned the reason
why we're so
confident in what we're doing we have
the professionals
executing it whether it's pfizer and
hopefully modernist
here shortly but really fedex and ups
right down through the pharmacies is
what's given us the confidence because
they do this every day
and they're demonstrating their
professionalism uh and their
organizational
culture in execution right the high
standards
and the accountability that they're
accepting yesterday i had a phone
uh a phone call with wes wheeler from
ups and richard smith from fedex the two
ceos
both of them were ensuring me uh as we
were looking at the weather maps
right for today in the northeast and
later in the week for the northwest
right how were we going to mitigate and
continue the flow of vaccines
these two leaders knew exactly
the weather report they had people
planning mitigating strategies for
distribution
and they were making contact with
customers they'd have establishing
uh rules saying that if somebody is not
there because of the weather
even though they're there we retain the
vaccine
it goes back secure and delivered the
next day i mean that's what these two
leaders and their companies are involved
in
i assured them that i would underwrite
a leader's decision in the delivery of
the vaccine
to ensure driver pilot safety and safety
of the vaccine
i i said leaders you make the call
i will underwrite the distribution
accordingly i was so impressed
by their ability to see themselves make
mitigating plans
and hold themselves accountable that i'm
here talking about it today and i just
wanted to pass
to the american people the the last
thing i would tell you uh as
as we're working through things we're
not stopping
uh you heard dr salawi talk about where
we're at with uh
continuing to bring additional vaccines
uh
you know to bear hopefully jansen
and astrazeneca but we're also working
inside of our manufacturing facilities
to expand
capacity every day um you know uh dr
slowly and i visited
uh catalint who's working uh to expand
their capability secretary was just
there
uh yesterday or the other day yesterday
um
between our visit dr sally myself and
uh the secretary's visit which has been
about 10 days we were able to get the
army corps of engineers there
uh to help them assess participate
and help really work through ideas to
expand capacity more rapidly
so that we could get more doses of
vaccine more rapidly
we actually think this is going to come
to fruition
and we'll have more vaccine from uh
potentially once eua
is done from moderna right so we are
always constantly trying to expand and
rapidly
increase the availability of safe and
effective vaccine for the american
people
uh mr secretary that concludes my
comments thank you general we're now
open for questions michael
thank you all operator we will now open
it up for questions a reminder when
asking please
state your name in publication and keep
your questions as short as possible
so we can get to as many as we can in
the time that we have i'll turn it over
to you know operator
thank you and if you would like to ask a
question please press the star one
and record your name if you need to
withdraw your question
press star 2. please announce your name
and outlet before asking your question
and our first question comes from samara
ophan with fox and your line is now open
hi uh this is irfan i'm a reporter at
vox for uh dr slowly and general parna
could you provide a little bit of
context here
as to the scale of this endeavor
compared to other vaccination
efforts in the past uh compared to say
smallpox polio or even
annual influenza vaccinations how much
bigger and how much faster
is this effort to roll out a coca-19
vaccine what is the relevant metric to
compare this to
yeah so if if we talk about vaccination
every year in the u.s between 80 million
and 100 million doses
of flu vaccines are distributed
and therefore we're talking about
something that's
maybe three or four times
uh bigger over a period that's
probably similar six months because the
flu vaccines are distributed from the
month of august through the month of
december
or or so so that's i would say the
distribution aspect
and the immunization aspect i think are
not
uh very significantly different and
that's the reason why
using the existing capabilities
and resources is is the appropriate and
the right thing to do and that's why
our level of confidence is very
significant of course upstream of that
by cutting any corners but rather by
using judgment in terms of which
vaccines to go after
and how to test them and running
everything in parallel
and taking the financial and operational
risk but not not
any uh cutting any corners and
touch wood up to now it's been
productive
yeah the other difference is is that uh
just for
context is influenza is
ordered and so based on orders from
hospitals doctors offices
pharmacies that is what industry
produces
and there's a very uh you know a
timetable associated with the
distribution
as dr salawi just talked about
in this case what we're doing with uh
the the covet vaccine is we're pushing
uh so we're coming up uh with our
availability
uh and then we're distributing based on
allocations
so that is you know it's a pull versus a
push
uh which makes planning um and execution
a little bit more uh difficult but as i
said the states have really transitioned
well on this
uh and their leadership is well involved
and that's why we're having so much
success
great thank you next question please
and our next question comes from sarah
murray with cnn
your line is now open hi
thank you guys very much um for doing
the call
um one of my questions is just
now that we're going to see a broader um
distribution effort around the modern
vaccine assuming that it's authorized
can you give us a better sense of what
kinds of
locations the vaccine will be headed to
that you know we haven't seen from the
pfizer vaccine
and just to follow on that we're hearing
some concerns from
states about the time table turnaround
of when they're getting the allocations
to when they need to figure out where
these places need to go
has there been any consideration about
that timetable yeah so i'll i'll turn
over to general purna
about the the medera question and but
but just so you know
uh we have uh the vice president
convenes a regular call
with governors uh usually it's on monday
afternoons
and uh general purna and i uh gave an
update on vaccine distribution as we
have been doing for
the last couple of months with the
nation's governors
and we got some really good feedback uh
on the last call
addressing exactly the question you're
raising uh as you know we had been
setting out the allocations on friday to
ship on sunday or to ship over the
weekend and then the following monday
tuesday wednesday
and the request from the governors was a
bit more advanced time on that and so
that's why you heard general purna say
uh he's now switched the cadence to
tuesday night
so tuesday night uh as he says uh uh uh
snap the chalk line sure yeah that's
exactly right and uh
uh and and tell them their allocations
so that they can have several more days
of planning
for us to initiate the shipping for the
following week but uh general on that or
on the madeira shipping locations
anything
so mr secretary you nailed it and it was
a great feedback by the governors and
her ability to
have some more time so what we did is
you know our goal is to get
all available doses of vaccine out to
the american people as we've talked
about
and so i just had to facilitate an
update on to understand exactly
what we thought was going to be
releasable and then i could snap the
chalk line and so my thing is
is normal repetition from now forward
uh the pfizer vaccine allocations will
be in on tuesday nights
and if uh eua is approved for moderna
they'll be also included in the tuesday
night
uh allocation and then then states can
just order uh based on their allocations
accordingly so i think
really a great effort there uh reference
moderna locations
uh i i would tell you that you're gonna
see a lot of the similar
uh capability and capacity or you know
delivered to the same
uh types of capability and capacity it
will start to expand
uh out to rural type areas i believe
uh as i remember reflecting on plans and
there'll be
more allocations towards uh nursing
homes uh
in execution of that nursing home
long-term health care facilities
um so current uh you know
primary uh hospitals still included
but i think you'll see more expansion of
the moderna vaccine
remember because of when the planning
and what was available
we were able to send out more moderna on
the first dose than we were able to send
out on pfizer
almost double great thank you general uh
next question please
and our next question comes from vicardo
pelosa
valdebar with associated press and your
line is now open
hi thank you for doing these calls uh
ricardo
alonso zaldivar with the associated
press
and uh my question is could you please
provide
an update on uh negotiations with pfizer
for additional doses of their vaccine
when would that be available and
can you provide some insight on the
earlier decision
to decline the option to purchase more
fisa vaccine
how will this impact the uh you know the
cadence
that general perna talks about the
cadence of delivery
uh thank you ricardo uh so uh obviously
we have to be careful we are engaged in
active negotiations on a procurement
uh matter so there's only so much we're
able to
to to discuss with you just as we've
said though publicly
uh we are in active discussions with
pfizer uh about exercising additional
options under our contract
the core issue as it was on the initial
question there's been so much
misunderstanding out there
is pfizer's ability to manufacture
by a date certain and we are working
with them
to provide them whatever assistance now
that they have identified some of their
production
challenges that they've got we've been
working with them on what assistance is
appropriate for us to provide
in order for us to secure additional
doses uh we're working towards uh
towards additional doses for that second
quarter you know they're right now
producing at their maximum capacity to
deliver on the 100 million
that is in the first tranche of the
contract with
us and we're providing manufacturing
support
uh as we have really from uh from the
beginning with pfizer
it's important to understand that the
fisa relationship
while it is very much part of operation
warp speed
is a different contractual relationship
than
the other five vaccine manufacturers on
the other five we are more intimately
engaged in the support of the
development and manufacturing
of their product on an ongoing basis
whereas the relationship that pfizer
wanted
with operation warp speed was the
guaranteed purchase
of vaccine if approved by the fda
and that that means that to date
we have had less visibility into their
manufacturing processes
their manufacturing capacities their
locations
and it supplies raw material issues
supply chain management
than we do with say a moderna or an
astrazeneca or a johnson and johnson
and so part of part of our ongoing
discussions is to remediate that and get
better visibility
into what they're doing what challenges
they're facing because they they have
you know they've made significant
commitments to us and others
and their manufacturing as you know uh
they ended up coming short half of what
they thought they would be able to
produce and had announced they'd be able
to produce
just in the year 2020. uh but general or
dr slowly could you give any additional
perspective i know dr saw you could
maybe talk particularly about
this misunderstanding that's out there
about the the the
additional options yes i think
any reasonable person would understand
that
we built a portfolio of vaccines
and took them into development in order
to ensure
that a one of them at least
makes it to the finish line and b if
more than one makes it to the finish
line
that we can accrue and accumulate
vaccine doses faster than if we were
relying on a single
provider so frankly
i hope once and for all it wouldn't make
sense whatsoever
to pre-order more from one vaccine
manufacturer than
any other one before we knew a vaccine
works
i don't know what rationale drives
people to ask that question
you wouldn't buy something before you
knew it works
if you had six opportunities to have one
provider provide you with what you're
needed number one
number two in order to ensure that we
would be in a position
to acquire more vaccine doses if and
when a vaccine had first signs
of performance we build options in each
and every one of our agreement
right that's the right thing to do
that's the thoughtful
way to allocate resources and taxpayers
money
as soon as we knew that the vaccine
works the
negotiation started and i think the
secretary really described the nature
of the partnership that we have
with different companies some are more
arms length i call them and others are
extremely more involved
and when pfizer was unable to
specify when vaccine doses
would be delivered you know we don't
need 100 million doses of vaccines
started in
in september or december of 20 20
21 we need them in the second quarter if
they make it into the second quarter and
frankly if they don't
i think there are enough vaccine doses
as you could see
through the first option agreement with
moderna
now doubling the amount of vaccine doses
we have and
with the janssen's vaccine coming in and
the astrazeneca after it
and the novovax vaccine i think there
the the the strategy is really happening
exactly as we planned it and we of
course would welcome having another 100
million doses of the pfizer vaccine
and we're negotiating with them
appropriately and
[Music]
you know our expectation is for that to
complete
shortly we have time for two more
questions
are you good with that i am i'm very
good with that my co-leader nailed it
you nailed it i mean you know ricardo
and uh it just this keeps getting asked
over and over again we'll keep
answering it uh we now have 900 million
doses of vaccine
that we have contracted for the delivery
of
we have options that increase that to a
total of 3
billion doses of vaccine
we have 100 million of moderna
set between now and march 31st 100
million
of pfizer between now and march 31st
a hundred million additional moderna in
the second quarter
we are working actively with pfizer and
i will just say that i am very
optimistic
that we will conclude a successful
result there
we have johnson and johnson
with 100 million in active production
single dose so that is a hundred million
people
right there astrazeneca uh i believe
it's three
and three hundred million on astrazeneca
okay
so we believe when you take 330 million
americans you take off the non-indicated
populations of about 70 million people
age 16
below age 16. uh you know if you just do
the math on that
you've we've got now the vaccine
contracted for with delivery we believe
subject of course to moderate approval
and success of
you know adding in uh either a johnson
and johnson or astrazeneca
uh we believe that we will have actually
surplus supplies of vaccine and that's
why the president signed his executive
order
that made the commitment that we will
take that surplus capacity
not just surplus vaccine but also
surplus manufacturing capacity
and use that for the benefit of the
world community so
one last question michael one last
question yes sir
and our last question comes from leanne
winick with
cbs news your line is now open
thank you good morning i'm curious about
on working with pfizer to increase
capacity are there any
shortages of supplies such as reagents
and is there any move or request to
invoke the defense production act
to help them acquire that and then just
a quick note i'm curious about the
christmas holiday
is everybody working straight through
christmas in terms of um
pfizer and the delivery people and the
administration
thank you yes uh thank you leanne so on
the on your first the first part of your
question with regard to pfizer
um again because as dr slowly described
it it's a more arms-length relationship
there
uh we have recently been informed by
them finally
of various challenges that they might
have in their in their manufacturing
uh and we will ensure that by whatever
mechanism we provide them full support
to ensure that they can produce for the
american people fulfill their
contractual commitments
as well as any assistance needed to
ensure that they're able to add
commitments to us
uh subject to to our needs so
we've done that already we've been
working with them as general purna can
talk about
uh we've been working to optimize where
companies will let us
working to optimize production you know
we've added significant capacity
to moderna through the work whether it's
the army corps of engineers work at
the catalan facility which is our fill
finish facility or our work at emergent
where we're actually doing the bulk
production for medera adding scale to
the bulk production capabilities there
so we hope to actually increase our
yields there even beyond what we've
talked about
and we will gladly do that as we've been
doing with pfizer to ensure that they
meet their commitments
but also so they can add additional
commitments to us and we'll use any
power
we need to to make that happen yeah i
i would just add we're we're we've
already been working with pfizer
just like all of our companies to help
them facilitate
enable execution um and so we are well
versed
on supply chain for materials and
well-versed on supply chain
for equipment that produces the vaccine
and so
i'm very comfortable in our ability to
help prioritize
and enable to meet our the effects that
we want
right safe and effective vaccines for
the american people
and could you talk a bit about the
holidays coming up oh uh yes i apologize
mr secretary
so uh the only day and it's really uh
christmas day
on friday uh is the day that uh we will
execute as required in emergency
distribution if something happens
through our cadence in the week
but the plan right now is not to deliver
on fridays and then you know we'll pick
up
we'll start producing or packaging
saturday and sunday
and begin our cadence the following week
so we think we can distribute all the
way through next thursday
being a good place you know to let uh
fry christmas day
you know except for emergencies and then
really start our cadence up saturday and
sunday
there's variances or nuances to that but
in general that's that's the plan
great uh so we're going to keep uh a
very active cadence of uh making
ourselves available to brief
you the members of the media so that you
have information as we go through this
really historic
mobilization and vaccination program but
even as even as we answer detailed
questions about the logistics about the
vaccines the development programs our
contracting
uh i just i hope we can step back a bit
and just do recognize this
is a momentous week uh this is just in
the
in the history of public health to have
a 94 plus vaccine safe and
effective approved within 11 months
of a novel pathogen hitting our shores
being distributed in the supplies of the
millions
to protect our health care workers and
to protect our most vulnerable citizens
and then within days we hope to have
another
94 plus effect safe and effective
vaccine added to our arsenal
with tens of millions of doses hundreds
of millions of doses coming in the
months ahead
is truly something historic and i hope
we can just recognize
that that protection for our heroes our
health care workers on the front lines
and our protection for our most
vulnerable comes through this we're not
at the end
but as the general says we're at the
beginning of the end of this terrible
pandemic so thank you for being with us
and we'll keep this cadence going with
you to make sure you've got the
information you need
thank you thank you all please send any
follow-up questions to our press office
at media
hhs.gov turn it over to the operator to
close out the call
thank you and that concludes today's
conference thank you for participating
you may disconnect at this time
[Music]
you